we need some champagne no you know she
gets crazy like somebody am stir up or
give her like a little special pill or
something really bad yeah you want to
make a back yeah so I'm like if we're
gonna lay it all out there that it's not
gonna be double standard I'm also gonna
lay it all out yeah oh you know I bowled
so now you know family melissa gorga and
Margaret Joseph spilling at the tea on
the Real Housewives of New Jersey season
9 reunion at Sarabeth's Tribeca in NYC
with et I mean Teresa came in hot
Melissa was sitting there like what I
feel like what's going on I was in shock
happened I was like wait what's
happening we just made pasta together
like two days ago
this is irrational I'm not even gonna
talk to her anymore don't even talk to
me don't talk to me don't talk to me
Alex from like you said I how exactly
would say louder what is your problem
this is very offended
she's very offended yes quickly very
very offended she's she's more sensitive
than she's normally yeah I but she's
normally a lot tougher
I feel like this the sensation we hurt
and I think she doesn't say she's hurt
and I think that could have resolved
everything yeah and I think that you
know she's taken back a little that
Jackie don't take no I don't like that
between you and I obviously you're gonna
throw something at me Teresa really
aren't you on parole white-trash [ __ ]
intimidated I think what works about
this group is the longest time it was
you and Teresa fighting about things
that were so deeply rooted in your
family and this year you had arguments
about things that were not about family
exactly so I think it helps when it's
like more about like hey I'm defending
this girl because I don't agree with
what you're saying when in reality what
I've done with when it comes to Teresa
and I and I think it's just from growth
and it could come with age but I'm done
with the double standard when Dolores
won against me for me been around 20
years giving isn't going against you the
glass case you didn't stick up for you
I'm now calling Teresa out on anything
she says to me that's a double standard
because I'm not here for it any longer
I've outgrown that I don't know where
did things between the two of you stand
today because this reunion gets very
heated at one point she like tries to
grab the cards out of Andy's hand I hit
somebody with them she wasn't trying to
hit Melissa okay now she wasn't it makes
it look like that yeah she was not
trying to hit Melissa um we're good
listen the truth is we are family we do
have kids that love each other we do
love each other we care about each other
do we agree on everything no but do I
think we're gonna be in each other's
lives forever yes so it's like I think
the show sometimes helps us because I
get so frustrated with her sometimes I'm
sure vice versa
did I wonder like I don't wanna call her
again for like a year but like no we
have to go on vacation together soon so
it's like we're gonna talk which makes
it better as hard as that is to like
comprehend it actually helps stick a
knife in my face gonna know what I'm
searching for another sister she ended
the season with you still on the hunt
for your third sister okay I may not be
out there right are there any updates on
that no not as no I'm fighting a bunch
of cousins but not as this or yet what's
your reaction to Melissa searching for
this Sister Sister right here is there
any chance that when the psychic said a
third sister that that sister could be
Teresa no this is my dad's child okay
she's not my dad's child I've been
saying it to me like where are you
getting this from
it's my dad having another child is what
they said okay it's not Teresa I know
all right if you had to sum up your
season nine experience with just a
couple words how would you sum it up for
me I think it was an awesome season like
it really was I would say fantastic and
fiery mm-hmm if that's it because was
fantastic and for me it was extremely
fiery as well fiery for everybody what
yes cheers to that actually to watch the
rest of you and then I gotta get those
cameras back on you guys so we can get
season 10 really thank you yes
soon enough
[Music]